warum wird jetzt über ein Verbot
diskutiert und nicht vor 5 Jahren und
das wissen auch die Wähler der AFD und
das weiß die Gesellschaft es wird jetzt
deswegen darüber diskutiert weil die AFD
so stark ist und das ist eben deswegen
ist diese Verbotsdebatte wirklich ein
Geschenk an die AFD und ein
Armutszeugnis für die Demokratie weil
ich finde wir müssen darüber diskutieren
wieso wird eine Partei trotz höcke trotz
solcher Position so stark weil es ist
nicht so das zeigen alle Umfragen wir
haben in der Gesellschaft keinen
Rechtsradikalismus der sich irgendwie
ausgeweitet hat und wir haben schon gar
nicht irgendwie 20% der Bevölkerung die
das gut finden aber wir haben ganz viele
Menschen die sich völlig politisch
heimatlos führen wir haben eine
Regierung die mit einer Überheblichkeit
einer Arroganz einer Planlosigkeit die
Leute im Grunde der AFD in die Arme
[Musik]
treibt